yo yo yo i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it's
november 24
2021 it's one day before thanksgiving
i'm in a good mood i've got a whole
bunch of people in the kitchen just feet
away from me cooking up a storm
it smells good and i'm excited to have a
couple days off and relax with friends
and family and food and i hope you will
do
that exact same thing and i hope it is
my hope for you that you will not read
any ridiculous think pieces usually
written by leftist lunatics about how to
deal with your crazy uncle or whether
you should have your family members
injected in the garage before they come
in the house or anything like that
have the holiday on your terms enjoy
your food enjoy your family enjoy your
friends enjoy your wine enjoy your
turkey enjoy your stuffing etc etc
anyway more about that at the end uh we
got a big show for you today i'm feeling
good about these stories uh you know
this gen socce lady uh she's the chief
white house liar she's back you know she
uh stepped away for about two weeks
because she had covet even though she
was vaccinated so make of that what you
will uh and she was asked uh by peter
ducey over at fox news she was asked
during the white house press briefing
yesterday whether joe biden owes kyle
rittenhouse an apology because old joe
did call kyle a white supremacist with
no evidence and
sake punted she did not answer the
question in any sort of an honest way
and then using the latest and greatest
technology on the internet i had connor
over here clip together
some things that saki was saying
juxtaposed you know that's one of my
favorite words with things that the
orange man used to say and we shall find
out who is the real liar that's story
number one story number two uh speaking
of orange man he was on
sean hannity last night and trump did a
big interview you know he usually does
these phoners once in a while he'll go
in person this one he actually did on
video so they were not in the room
together but he was on with sean hannity
and he went on a tear about the
mainstream media and i thought it was
pretty solid so i wanted to show that to
you guys and then finally our third
story
from the mental institution known as
msnbc with their 87 boxes of pundits who
all think the exact same thing uh they
are starting to realize it's it's quite
extraordinary they are starting to
realize that democrat policies that
progressive policies actually destroy
cities because suddenly they're
realizing that all the cities that they
live in are crumbling and that they're
not arresting people and crime is
running rampant it's quite
uh wonderful when you see that these
people become self-aware you know what i
mean it's it's pretty amazing it's like
a robot coming to life it's pretty
incredible and then of course we'll also
talk about nancy pelosi who guess what
people
she's moving to florida yeah that's
right leftist whack job northern cali
uh
you know just awful really just awful i
was you see i was trying to be nice
there i had to think for a second but
she's just an awful person she's just an
awful person nancy pelosi uh she's gonna
retire in florida not in california but
in florida because she wants to avoid
all the taxes and the capital gains and
everything else and she just bought a
25 million dollar waterfront house so it
makes you wonder first where'd she get
25 million dollars she's been in
congress since 1804 like where did that
money come from how'd she get that rich
25 million million with an m
uh and uh you know she's so concerned
about climate change you know these
people are always freaking out about
climate change why would you move to the
water much like that barack obama guy
martha's vineyard much like that bill
gates guy up in seattle yeah that's what
they do it's almost as if they don't
believe in any of this stuff and they're
using it as a way of just controlling
you do you think that could possibly be
anyway uh i'll do this more at the end
but david sacks uh my buddy and the
founder of craft ventures he had a funny
tweet this morning about uh nancy pelosi
basically saying uh that this should be
a sitcom you know this crazy leftist uh
congresswoman moves to florida and now
she's around all these conservatives and
i think there's something to it like
maybe we should be writing a sitcom
about this who should play nancy pelosi
that is my question of the day who
should play nancy pelosi
in this sitcom that maybe i'll produce
i'm not kidding i actually think it's a
great idea i already sent that a couple
feelers to people so you can't steal it
you network people that are watching
this show it was sak's idea and now i'm
talking about it uh so if you want to
let us know who should play
nancy pelosi in this wacky sitcom maybe
a curb your enthusiasm style thing not
necessarily a you know soundtrack
situation laugh track situation let us
know you can join the live chat right
now at reubenreport.locals.com
now let's do a show
all right first up jen saki okay you
know it she can't tell the truth she
just lies and lies and lies and lies
well peter ducey from fox was basically
like lady why is joe biden not
apologizing for calling kyle rittenhouse
a white supremacist there's no evidence
that kyle rittenhouse is a white
supremacist and here's
sake president ever apologized to the
acquitted kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse for suggesting online and on
tv that he is a white supremacist
well let's be clear what we're talking
about here this is about a campaign
video released last year that used
president trump's own words during a
debate as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and
president trump as we know from history
and as many of you covered didn't just
refuse to condemn militia groups on the
debate stage he actively encouraged them
throughout his presidency so
you know what we've seen are the tragic
consequences of that when people think
it's okay to take the law into their own
hands instead of allowing law
enforcement to do its job and the
president believes in condemning hatred
division and violence that's exactly
what was done in that video but if
you're saying that it was just a
campaign video it wasn't the president
also gave an interview where he said
this written house was part of a militia
coming out of illinois have you ever
heard this president referring to trump
say one negative thing about white
supremacists these are all things
none of this was proven in the trial and
kyle rittenhouse is saying that the
president had actual malice in defaming
his character is that what happened here
the president spoke to the verdict last
week
he has obviously condemned
the hatred and division and violence
we've seen around the country by groups
like the proud boys
and groups that
that individual has posed in photos with
um but beyond that i'll leave it to his
comments around the verdict
all right so look jensaki is just a
bloviating useless liar she didn't even
really answer
the question there it's like she could
just say you know what actually the
president does walk back those comments
there's no evidence that kyle
rittenhouse
is a white supremacist she could even
say you know the president isn't
thrilled with the decision that's
basically what the statement that the
president released said that he's sort
of angry about it something to that
effect which is pretty bad because we
shouldn't have one branch of government
attacking another branch of government
but putting that aside she could say
something like that and that would let
it go but she can't instead she still
doubles down on what a racist trump is
and how trump is the one who has
instigated and fanned the flames of
racism throughout the nation and he
never condemned racism he often winked
at racism right well you're not going to
believe this so conor here okay this guy
he sits at a computer okay he's got a
couple screens there he's wearing some
sort of device on his head and he's
always typing okay he's typing he's
doing things i see his little mouse
moving across the screen it's incredible
i don't know exactly what kind of it's a
computer that you have there okay it's a
computer it's incredible and it puts
videos on things and then he said to me
dave we could splice together some video
of sake and trump showing that
she's a liar and i said my god we can do
that and you can do that all right here
three minutes later he put this together
as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and you
had people and i'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups
racism is evil
and those who cause violence in its name
are criminals and thugs
including the kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists
and other hate groups that are repugnant
to everything we hold dear as americans
as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups in one
voice our nation must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy
these sinister ideologies must be
defeated
hate has no place in america
connor ladies and gentlemen at a
computer what what is that a dell or
what do we have over there gateway i
don't know what do we have it's a it's
an apple it's an incredible
anyway you see what i'm trying to show
you guys they lie about everything
they lie
we know they're lying they know we know
they're lying and they continue to lie
and they will not stop so you know what
we're gonna do we are going to cut that
40 second or so little thing that conor
put together and we are going to post
that on youtube in and of itself so
every time one of your blue and on npc
friends or somebody tells you that
donald trump did not condemn racism and
joe biden is such a great guy and all of
that stuff you can show them that 40
second clip i already posted it on
twitter it'll be up on youtube very
shortly just by itself just so that's
easily digestible and you can see it but
this is what they do they don't mind
lying because she knows it's like it's
very interesting i mean just think about
it at a psychological level if you were
just lying about something big we've all
lied about things right everybody has
lied period we all have you should try
not to lie i try not to lie but we've
all lied about things sometimes it's a
little white lie sometimes it's a big
lie okay
if you
knew that no matter how big your lie was
you could continue to lie you might
continue to do it it wouldn't
necessarily be the best thing it would
probably be the worst thing uh because i
believe the truth is what sets the world
right and we're in an unfortunate
situation right now where we have a lack
of truth permeating throughout the
system but if you knew as jen saki does
that she can lie about virtually
anything she lies knowing that there are
people like connor with computer
machines okay that can splice together
these things using the latest and
greatest technology it's incredible what
program do you use
premier he has a program called premier
it's incredible okay
she knows that despite
the fact that we can expose her that the
internet exists and every time she lies
we can show those lies she continues to
lie
so why do they do it at some level
they're just gaslighting you at another
level she knows as i've talked about
many times before that the lies will be
laundered through the system meaning if
she says it what she just said will be
played on cnn and then the average work
you know viewer of cnn or msnbc will be
like oh my god it does turn out that
trump never condemned anything and joe
biden is a good man and maybe kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist and
the statement stands on itself because
they know that they will not be called
out and then when they do get called out
say when we put up a video like that or
fox news and again that was peter ducey
right there with the pointed questions
when they talk about it somehow that
will be some sort of conspiracy theory
or right wing
maniac lunatic thingy that they're
always talking about those crazy people
and the lizards and the whole thing
anyway we are going to splice that i
hope that you can see the truth
and that i hope
that you will spread the truth amongst
your friends right why why the hell not
huh
guys i want to talk to you for a second
about raycon you know the holidays are
officially here and if you're like me
and you prefer chilling at home with
family and leftovers to the chaos of
black friday ain't it the truth then you
probably prefer doing your holiday
shopping online today you can save big
on a gift your loved ones will use every
day raycon wireless earbuds whether i'm
listening to them when i'm doing my
daily cardio or have them with me on the
plane when i'm flying to an event i like
to keep my raicons close with seamless
bluetooth pairing and a comfortable
noise isolating fit you too can start
listening right away and keep listening
for hours the audio quality is amazing
comparable to what you get from other
premium brands except except raycon is
about half the price the new everyday
earbuds come with three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds its best with just
the right amount of bass set them to
balance mode when you're catching up on
episodes of the reuben report raycon
offers eight hours of play time and a 32
hour battery life there's also a
built-in mic and you can take calls on
your earbuds at the press of a button so
this holiday season give your loved ones
a gift they can use every day for calls
or music for work or play at home or on
the go go to buy raycon com ruben today
to unlock exclusive deals for up to 20
off your recon order but hurry this
offer is available for a limited time
only and if you don't want to miss it
then you got to do it now that's by
raycon dot com slash ruben to unlock 20
off your raycons by raycon.com reuben
and now back to me all right
donald trump former president donald
trump the man the media still obsesses
over still needs to be the worst man on
earth so that they don't have to look in
the mirror and see that they actually
are the evil ones
he was on sean hannity's program on fox
news last night it was a wide-ranging
interview but i thought this was the
most interesting part donald trump
talking about the media
they are corrupt they are and i say it
and i don't want to say it much
but i say it and i hope in the future i
won't have to they are the enemy of the
people and we could have a country that
would be able to heal and get together
except the media foments it they're so
corrupt and you know i called it i came
up with the term fake news a long time
ago i don't know if i'll get credit for
that but that's okay the fake news but
it's really the corrupt news it's
corrupt what they do and they're so
important it could be well important
they used to have a high approval rating
now they have the lowest i think they
have a lower rating than
mitch mcconnell which is pretty good i
tell you what they have a rating that
now is people people have gotten wise to
it they've just gotten wise to it
god it will never ever cease to amaze me
that that golden man
with whatever is going on with his hair
is more authentic than virtually every
other politician in america even today
and i put that notwithstanding a couple
of the guys that you know i like like
ted cruz and rand paul and obviously
there's a couple others but
it's just incredible the best part of
that of course is that he still wants
credit for the phrase fake news which is
sort of hilarious like what what do you
want you want an award should they hand
him some sort of golden statue you
donald trump created the term fake news
anyway getting to the to the nuts and
bolts of what he said he said they're
corrupt now that is just obviously true
the mainstream media is evil and corrupt
at one point yesterday i verified it
myself
nowhere at cnn.com was there anything
about the car ramming event in wisconsin
from a couple days ago okay somehow that
was not on cnn's front page
that is a type of fake news when they
will not show you something because it
goes against their narrative that is a
type of fake news fake news is not just
oh headline doesn't match what's in the
article or headlines completely made up
sometimes avoidance of a story is
actually fake news he said that they're
the enemy of the people which i think
was a nod to my buddy michael malus who
has been saying for a long time and i
like to quote him on it the corporate
press is the enemy of the people so he
is right about that he says we have a
country that could come together doesn't
it feel like that like it actually does
if these people were not constantly
meddling
if they were not constantly trying to
push you into thinking that your
neighbor is a racist and a bigot and a
nazi and all of these things and maybe
doing a little bit of a better job
honestly reporting what's happening and
not just the things that fit their
narrative and then not hiding the things
that don't fit their narrative don't you
think the country could kind of come
together but there's not a lot of
dollars in that i suppose you know like
i'm not saying i do a perfect job here
and i obviously make fun of the lefties
left and right but i think if you watch
this show you know that one of the
things i'm trying to do is get us to a
place
um
where where we're a little more decent
where we're a little more thoughtful
where we can heal some of this stuff do
you think that that's what they want
it's so dangerous and this was the
danger you can watch a video that i did
the day after the 2016 election we were
i just moved into my other house we
didn't even have my old studio that you
remember in the garage we didn't even
have that studio yet there was
construction going on i'm sitting there
off my computer in the backyard it's
very loud day after day after trump got
elected and i did not vote for trump
that time around okay and there's a
video of me still considering myself
part of the left saying hey maybe this
is a moment
where if we give this guy a chance
that some good things can happen but if
we keep calling him racist what if it
turns out that he does some good things
what if we don't get into more wars what
if the economy is good what if things
are generally good in the country and
that's pretty much what happened let's
remove covet from it for a sec that's
pretty much what happened but once
you've done that once you've called half
the country nazis and bigots you've
painted yourself into the corner right
it's not what you've done to them all
right you've said mean things about
people people get mean things said about
them all the time right like every time
the new york times or daily beast calls
me a nazi now or whatever they call me
it's like oh glad you guys are still
paying attention to me i suppose but
it's what you're doing to yourself
because you can never be like oh you
know you're not going to believe this
guys that hitler that hitler guy and the
nazis that i've been telling you about
they're actually not so bad
so that's why they always double down
they always double down they just got to
do more and more and more of it but in
any event what trump said there was
correct and the more that the media
crumbles and we know that their ratings
are crumbling and everything else the
more they will become hysterical in
order to keep people paying attention
but at this point i think you should
basically go on the assumption that if
cnn says something it pretty much is not
true
and and maybe not every specific thing
as i said yesterday it's like if they're
reporting something about a a hurricane
i don't know ballpark i guess they're
probably going to get it right although
there was that video of anderson cooper
pretending that he was standing in like
you know five feet of water and then you
and then if you zoom out on the shot you
see people like in this much water
behind them so they yeah all right i
tried there you see what i did i tried
to give them the benefit they lie about
everything that's all you need to know
uh okay let's move on to story number
three speaking of liars uh there's this
uh cable news channel called msnbc it
employs such luminaries as joy read
but this is not from joy reid's show
this is from morning joe
with joe scarborough and i guess the
other lady is his wife and it's a whole
bunch of leftists just lying about
everything all the time it's just boring
nonsense whatever
however once in a blue moon something
happens where you see these people
actually realize that it's their own
policies that are destroying their own
cities and it's quite extraordinary to
watch them realize it in real time so
here's a panel there's about 87 talking
heads and they're talking about san
francisco and crime and they're slowly
it's like their brains are turning on
they're slowly realizing that these
cities like san francisco and portland
are run by leftists just like them
so joe while some of these images of
course are shocking to look at they're
absolutely not surprising to anyone who
lives in san francisco given what's
happened in the last few years there
which is the district attorney has
signaled there we're just not going to
prosecute property crimes we're going to
do it at a much lower rate than it's
ever been done in fact it will be a
misdemeanor if you steal less than 950
dollars that was a proposition a
referendum that passed in that city all
the signals and it's not just san
francisco but it's what we're talking
about here are that if you want to go
and steal stuff we're going to sit back
and let it happen or at least we're not
going to prosecute you after we catch
you
well i mean it's in san francisco and by
the way
i'm not sure what the mayor of san
francisco is talking about we must stop
this
it's been happening for a couple of
years now we
a good friend of ours went into a
louboutin store to get a pair of sweats
about 10 people stormed into the store
pulled out guns and just started piling
uh stuff into suitcases it's been san
francisco is out of control portland is
out of control and and you look
important you're right willie
laws have consequences
and and
and
i don't know
who sent the memo out
that like over the last couple years was
a dawning of the age of aquarius
and we actually didn't have to worry
about crime and punishment but we do
we do and when you don't these are the
consequences
i mean
just spectacular tell me that's not just
spectacular all of those little tv box
leftists including although he didn't
say anything in that segment that's
chief race huckster al sharpton uh all
of them suddenly realizing that it's
progressives who run portland it's
progressives who run san francisco it's
progressives who run new york it's
progressives who run la
it's progressives who run seattle and
that it's the mayors and it's the da's
and all of these things and you can sort
of see it and sort of they don't know
exactly what to say and then joe and my
god did you hear that guys joe has a
friend who went to buy louboutin am i
pronouncing it correctly lou baton who
went to buy louboutin sweats which just
sounded expensive so while we were
playing the clip i asked the guys to
google it louboutin sweatpants cost 2
300 bucks
no conservative is spending twenty three
hundred dollars on sweatpants okay that
is obviously he's a lefty his friends
are lefties they love money and they
love making other people feel guilty
about money while they hoard money for
themselves and buy twenty three hundred
dollar sweatpants poor joe with the
friend with my friend couldn't get to do
it
i'm literally wearing the same pair of
sweatpants i've had for like five years
right now they're
ratty and they're old and i love them
i love them
anyway i don't like these people very
much in case you can't tell speaking of
people i don't like and related to the
story of sort of the ridiculousness of
leftism what these people do like
parasites they go to places and they
destroy cities nancy pelosi uh who of
course is one of the most powerful
congresswomen in america i'm fairly
certain she's also an alcoholic she um
she just bought
a 25
million dollar house in florida now do
we have an image of the house there's
the house that's nancy's new house and
my god what is all that blue stuff
right beyond her house it looks sort of
wet
um it looks wavy is that water and i
thought that the water was rising and
sea levels were coming you'd have to be
a psychopath to buy a 25 million dollar
house if you were a good progressive
lefty who goes to climate conferences
and tells people not to
you know drive their cars while you fly
there in private jets etc etc
but she's a hypocrite of course and
she's moving to florida where of course
she would tell you that ron desantis has
mismanaged covid but she's going even
though she's 8 000 years old and
obviously in a high-risk group because
of covid but she knows it's all [ __ ]
this is what these people endlessly do
so anyway this picture leaked oh and i
should also address it's like where did
this woman get 25 million dollars i mean
i get it through poli this is what
politics is right like you're just
connected to all of these people her
husband is super rich is he what was he
he's like a finance guy or something
yeah so and they're loosely somehow
isn't she like the second cousin 14
times removed from gavin newsom or
something like he's a traitor or
something like that anyway
it's like she's got 25 million dollars
for a home this woman should not be
governing over you she's governing over
you idiots in san francisco that's what
she's actually doing um but anyway david
sacks my buddy from craft ventures who
was one of our investors in locals uh
from the all-in podcast uh he had a
great tweet on this because i just think
this is just so perfect
he tweeted out i have a pitch for a
sitcom a progressive speaker of the
house using insider trading games
retires to a rich florida community
filled with the very people she used to
demonize and moralize against including
a former president and
top golf pro high jinks ensues too
unrealistic then he went on to say pilot
episode in order to add staff quarters
onto her mansion former speaker must
battle byzantine permitting process
thereby drawing the ire of local
bartender and environmental leader alexa
obasado caballo
so my question at the beginning of the
show and we've got a whole bunch of
answers from the locals community at
report.locals.com is who should play
nancy pelosi
in this sitcom i'm not kidding i think i
might get in on this and help produce
this sitcom maybe we do it as like a
weekly old school like golden girls
style half hour sitcom i know that's not
exactly what people are watching these
days but like maybe we could do like a
kind of throwback thing or it should be
like curvier enthusiasm or something
before i get to some of your answers
though i want to show you some of the
other houses of some of these rich
people because they're very concerned
about rising sea water right and it's
coming you're going to drown you're
going to be sitting in your hot tub
drinking your champagne and the water's
going to get you here's barack obama's
house oh there we go there's barack he
moved to martha's vineyard i think
that's about a 12 million dollar house
right off
all of that blue stuff the water and you
can see it could just flow over and it
could you know just take michelle out to
sea but i guess barack doesn't care
about that and then there's that bill
gates guy who's very excited to inject
all of your children with experimental
drugs well here's his house up in
seattle how much is that house it was
something like 70 million bucks or
something like that yeah it doesn't even
matter but bill why would you have a
dock there man i mean that dock could
overflow with water and be pushed onto
your house and break the windows
oh hypocrisy you
know no bounds do you uh so anyway i
want to know a couple actresses that
could play nancy pelosi my guess my the
first one that popped to mind to me
is kirsty alley here's the alley from
cheers uh you know she's a little older
from the cheers days i think if they put
her up in some makeup and it was like a
really over the top and kirstie ali is a
conservative so it would just be perfect
tallway from the locals community says
the only real answer
to who can play nancy pelosi in a sitcom
is joy bayar
they share similar looks similar age
similar mentality it wouldn't be a
stretch for her to get into character
that is that is very very true they
actually do kind of joy looks like a
slightly heavier version of nancy pelosi
i suppose uh but yeah like it works but
she wouldn't take the gig that's a
problem we need a conservative because
none of these people are joyless and
have no sense of humor so we're gonna
have to find a conservative that can do
it zionists says bette midler should
play nancy pose yeah she's another
hysterical crazy leftist bet midler once
called me a racist on twitter uh which
was very upsetting because i really
liked first wives club you know with her
and goldie hawn i really did enjoy it
now every time i watch it i'm looking at
her going she thinks i'm a racist very
annoying a dragon hawk says one of jeff
dunham's puppets i like that i like that
jeff dunham's puppets because you know
that feels like pelosi is basically a
puppet at this point uh and let's see uh
jumping jeff says nancy pelosi could be
played by grateful dead's bertha
uh nuclear patrick another pelosi
casting suggestion anthony fauci in drag
oh the drag options
are fantastic so we that's a little bit
of poetic license that we could do there
right where it's like we take the ideas
it's based on nancy pelosi but instead
we get it as like an aging male
trans or cross-dressing
congresswoman man caesar who moves to
florida to enjoy all of the safety and
financial security of florida while
they have infected their home city
i'm going to work on this i'm not
kidding i'm actually excited to work on
this do i have anything else to do i
guess i have a few other things going on
at the moment but
guys uh part two of my interview with
melanie kirkpatrick all about
thanksgiving which is tomorrow if you
want a little background on thanksgiving
in case you don't want to bludgeon your
family members with politics and you
don't want to beat them over the head
with who got injected with what you
could actually watch this interview it's
only about a half hour we talk about the
history of thanksgiving and i think you
might learn a little something
uh and you know what
i think that's about it for today uh i
will not be online tomorrow or friday
we're not doing shows tomorrow not doing
shows to friday i am a benevolent leader
around here i want you guys to go and
eat with your families and friends and
all that stuff we've got family here
already um so there'll be no more dms
this week and actually we won't have dms
on monday or tuesday i'm going to
florida
i cannot say why
uh and i'll be back on wednesday i have
my reasons okay uh i gotta go take care
of some business all right i can't say
too much but you know i'm just going to
florida no big deal all right that's all
i'm saying right now
uh anyway i just want you to enjoy
thanksgiving that's really the message
today just enjoy thanksgiving i hope you
have a wonderful time with friends and
family i hope you enjoy some food i hope
it's not about politics i hope you can
uh maybe mend some relationships that
need to be mended in all of this
craziness that we're all dealing with
and i hope you just eat a lot and drink
a lot and unbuckle the pants after and
watch some football
and
whatever else you enjoy doing and i just
want to say i am very thankful
uh for this country i'm very thankful
for the freedoms that we still have i'm
thankful for my team here i'm thankful
for those of you who watch i'm
especially thankful for all of you in
the locals community who have become a
community for me
uh in in a more intimate way than just
the the usual stuff that you get online
so that being said happy thanksgiving
everybody
and i'll be back next wednesday